welcome to this video it's Thomas Tallis
yeah I feel like I played them so often
but it's not that often just eight games
and okay we have the kingside fianchetto
in effect and again I'm going with this
a six business okay and he's playing a
for an interesting question now should I
play gay let's go for the ball and
probably it's quite ok against the set
up with them with both nights once f 3
and C 3 C and F porn okay so h 4 and a
form where do you put your king an
interesting move d 5
I wonder ever should take on c3 and then
play if I for is this rubbish an
interesting idea let's try that is a 5
at the end now k he's got a five but yes
that anyway takes takes takes on c3b
takes a five a five on b5 is called
bishop jakes b 5 which is kind of
embarrassing 97 txtx and she takes on a
six hmm i am not shown
check it's interesting and so let's go
for it I wonder what happens actually if
I t25 is that is set an idea takes takes
Queen e7 when Queen trade would be okay
I think there should be three has a
night f6 piling up on the porn huh
very very unconventional I tix with that
actually interesting check I thought
that is interesting and because of that
very rigid pawn structure is double pond
and nights might be decent pieces for
that just we should deform maybe 85 is
also probably move in general
opening it up because i'm not super well
coordinated at the mood really not
question is am I really threatening on
d5 I might be if he castles 95 I think I
can play that getting rid of this Bishop
only three also would be excellent
because of my shaky King there i would
like to Castle here those very
elementary needs I like I want to Castle
sometimes really really a pressing in
those in those kind of unconventional
openings because you don't get cancelled
so quickly and sometimes you really feel
okay do I really manage that okay that's
an interesting move just looking at c7
now
I can't cancel due to the pin Matt I
just doesn't look good really doesn't
see seven if I go 97 queen coin cell
castles
okay i'm so done down on time and
naughty i have to play Queen six seven
castles I'm threatening rook c8 yeah
that is ok I think and they have Queens
to 795 possibly okay but Quincy six is a
double attack so I have to castle first
okay so if I castle now I'm blundering
stage six um so um Queenie for cool man
that's also not to it Queenie for Quincy
seven still cannot castle okay i have
joe i have to even if i'm giving away
aged six but ok he has rookie one right
after that so that was stupid that's a
stupid move he just says rookie one and
I don't have a good reply I was thinking
I might have compensation a little bit
but he has rookie one and then I have to
play Queen d 8 which is entirely
entirely ridiculous if I have to go back
really what is that how am I not I'm
just perpetually him here at least let's
do it let's do it perpetual on the Queen
ty morning so let's see here he cannot
escape that
rookie one maybe look II one rookie one
it might be on night 5s animals 95 then
nightly hive Queen B 6 night f3 yeah
that's that's sufficiently unclear i
think maybe you can check with the noid
actually for Queen sack I could be on
it's not not ridiculous now we chatted
so let's go here try to play for his
weekend kingside queen age three this
kind of thing
so he could save himself there with with
rookie one saving the saving the Queen
cannot take you to checkmate but still I
don't know if this is a very lucky
configuration file I've got rookie 5
rupee eight on don't know
he lost the thread there a little bit
King age 7 was also possible but rookie
5 rupee eight is good I think and I my
head on the clock now that's it's nice
so let's just go for that not think too
long
oh it's totally not not paying I'm not
reacting in any way here what check okay
then I'm checkmating you white resigns
okay yeah that was a lucky win yeah okay
that that idea is maybe maybe fish yeah
i know i had my original idea was to do
this but i wasn't sure what happens
after that move the problem is said
after b5 he can take and they it's not
good anyway yeah but i don't know i
thought maybe i can just play a slow
move like this on Knight f6 i wasn't
sure what this is but then I had this
idea to take the X takes the check
things now thought maybe I can do
something against his weakened pawns but
of course this is very recap if okay
this is a very theoretical discussion
let's say what theoretically is wrong
hypothetical if the Pawn would be on g7
I would be in very good shape I think
but it isn't I gettin I don't get
castled Queen c4 is a strong move 97
here and yeah now I decided to just
castle and and yeah it's just wrong the
problem is he has rookie one now and I
don't know why I didn't do that after
that is better I only have bad moves now
Queen da door 95 both looks bad but he
took surprisingly and that makes things
rather uncomfortable Oh f28 I miss them
threatening 95 and rooks is seven ok and
that's it trapping the Queen you had to
be honest I just thought I overlooked
Ruby one and I thought I can perpetually
meant for him first a little bit and
then think but he has this move right
now yeah it changes its a bit a bit
messy but why does of course better here
yeah and now if he just goes Kim G to
everything is very neat for white I
don't get to age free but he allowed
that it's still probably not so bad but
the engine is just giving this with
white basically winning yeah he he
simply he absolutely didn't didn't react
to this idea and he I've already better
until yeah winning him yeah if he goes
route before I actually wanted to do
this which is good okay the engine gives
this move which is of course very
powerful very nice at it check yeah and
white falls apart yeah that opening idea
was probably to create and okay at the
end he allowed that bed medium okay well
thanks for watching